boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake I'm
super pumped to be talking about
holistic mental healing we have Jonathan
Toniolo joining us on the show hi Tony
hi thanks for coming on thanks for
having me super pumped for this episode
was awesome meeting you at the
consciousness hacking party that we were
just both that yeah
a couple weeks ago and after striking up
a great conversation to I was like this
needs to happen I'm pumped for this
those don't know Tony's background
Tony's a graduate student at California
Institute of integral study see is
focused on psychedelic therapy trauma
integration and developmental psychology
and you can find his hai existence
writer profile in the link in the bio as
well as his Facebook profile link all
right Tony let's set things off with one
of our favorite questions ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world big question yeah I think
it depends on what you're reading and
what your intuition says I mean if you
read Steven Pinker the world is getting
better and better we're on an upward
curve you know and if you read someone
like Chris Ryan or derekjjensen or
what's going or the news for that matter
you know the world's not doing too good
but my intuition tells me that we're a
caterpillar go into a cocoon
disintegrating into the chrysalis
hopefully be reborn in something more
beautiful
what do you think some main principle
that we need to embody for us to most
effectively fly like that butterfly
mm-hmm I think we need to process our
trauma and confront our shadows mm-hmm I
think a lot of the reasons why we have
the crisis the many crisis that we have
right now is because of disconnection
from nature mm-hmm because we're
disconnected from ourselves tonight and
so dive into that work that personal
work figuring out your trauma figuring
out what's blocking from connecting with
other people in the world around you
dealing with that head-on yeah so it's
almost as though then we're born as this
gorgeous gem that can express itself
creatively and bring beautiful fruits
into the world yet there's some sort of
like maybe like a dust or some sort of
stuff on the gem that makes it like
harder to shine and so the idea is that
you kind of have to like polish it off
to Pauls yourself oh yeah yeah well I'm
not sure I've are you familiar with the
Charles Eisenstein at all you just have
very recently yeah oh yeah yeah well he
he talks a lot about civilization and
the harlot it's done to this planet but
he sees it more as a journey and
necessary journey
so although we come into this world
perfectly perfect beings the descent
into chaos and having the dust come on
earth is part of the the overall journey
and it's necessary part yeah yeah it's
supposed to be a hard game right yeah it
wouldn't be interesting it could be
interesting otherwise yeah you like we
always make the joke like you come and
you like immediately know that you come
from source and you know your North Star
and like it's super easy to get there
and everything else around you is just
the cakewalk would be like this is
boring mm-hmm but then when all of those
things have scarce involved in them it
becomes more fun and that's why
apparently there's a long line of VI the
long list line of people that want to
come souls that want to incarnate one
yeah we're the lucky ones so yes let's
talk about your journey mm-hmm who were
you growing up and how did you get
interested in what you care about today
sure yeah so I grew up in a small island
in South Carolina Hilton Head Island
grew up in immigrant household my
family's from Brazil and had a pretty
you know standard normal suburban
upbringing but I was always very curious
about the world and always asking
questions you know his kids do but I
kept that curiosity with me for up until
my adult years and so in high school I
read a lot of philosophy and read a lot
of psychology and one big triggering
event for me was the death of my best
friend in high school
howdy pass
it was a car accident yeah but so that
event kind of like shot me into this
deep dark depression and asking deeper
questions about death and the meaning of
life and and that was a very challenging
time and then one summer during college
I tried psilocybin mushrooms and that
totally would have opened my mind and
made me come to terms with his death and
a lot of the questions that I was
grappling with out the time about
meaning about death in life and so what
were those realizations then that
fundamentally we are okay mmm and that
there is purpose and meaning to our
lives do we create that purpose or
meeting ourselves on our journey sir
what is the funda me that's a good
question see I've been grappling with
this notion of fate and free will
yeah yeah yeah so we just created our
own purpose yeah I think it's probably
my sense is this a mixture of both yeah
so do you feel like it's one big
artistic expression of creation that
we're all in yeah yeah one bigger just
an expression of creation yes it was
Carl Sagan and say we are the universe
experience itself yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
okay so then yeah take us past the set
of Simon experience sure sure so after
that experience I struggled to make
sense of it and integrate it and decided
to drop out of college where I was going
to USC at the time
and spend some time in Colorado just
reading a lot dive into Alan Watts and
Eckhart Tolle and just really trying to
make sense of what happened and
eventually stumbled across CI is found
out that Alan Watts was a professor
there and my heart everything just
clicked I was like that's right need to
be mm-hmm
and so I planned accordingly didn't made
it happen
so okay and that's how you landed then
to do your undergrad yeah he's in there
they had they had a bachelor's
completion program yeah so since I
dropped out I still had enough credits
and accepted and finished within a year
so and then how did you so this is a CIS
is such an interesting place yeah the
professors they're very interesting like
you just said that like Alan Watts and
whatnot but then also the disciplines
there are super multidisciplinary and
then that's actually what you got your
bachelor's in it's multidisciplinary and
studies introduce players that
interdisciplinary so then walk us
through that process like how did you
get to pick what you know this is a very
important thing actually actually I
would like to really plant a flag and
how important this is because I agree
it's like is this we're just we're
carving ourselves into these ruts of
like I'm going to only go for econ or
only psych or only CS or whatever and it
is it's disheartening sometimes because
a lot of people in life succeed when
they combine two disparate fields
together or three or four or ten and
then you get a more robust worldview
mm-hmm and it actually makes you a
better dialectic with your family your
friends coworkers people online yeah
anyway totally so many good reasons why
yeah I mean why don't you speak about
this interdisciplinary pursue yeah sure
yeah well I think you you have
right but that takes a lot of work and
time to dive into different aspects of
knowledge and reality and I think a lot
of people are scared of the uncertainty
that comes with that because you know if
you just pick econ or engineering your
business let's say you have a pretty
clear path in front of you know if
you're just cherry picking about you
know philosophy and this and that and
that there's a lot more uncertainty
there but I think moving into the future
it's gonna be a crucial skill you know
our worlds becoming much more complex
and you know it's not just a matter of
us becoming multidisciplinary thinkers
it's a matter of combining these experts
in siloed disciplines together to form a
multidisciplinary collective
intelligence yeah yes yeah and you were
as you were speaking you it also
reminded me that as soon as we open up
more positions in the post study period
of people's lives that initial study
period when we open up positions that
are for interdisciplinary thinkers and
doers and creators then that'll make it
like more like you have a clear track
like when you say I've picked these five
disciplines and then yours like damn
that's a good set of disciplines get
into this position that we need help
with yeah yes if like that I mean a lot
of as far as I understand a lot of
companies and Silicon Valley want you
know to hire philosophy grads yeah as
they're just so well-versed in a bunch
of defenders so yeah and it's also
becoming more more important to have
philosophers and ethicists aligned with
the bio engineers and the neuro
engineers and the AI engineers and
watching devs all this type of stuff
absolutely yeah
yeah let's talk about your journey with
spirit so tell us about every love-hate
relationship okay how so yeah so I
Catholic
to Sunday school first communion the
works right 30 committed Catholic
growing up and once I started
questioning Catholicism and exploring
atheism a bit more I just had so much
resentment towards a religion and
anything that could be considered spirit
and then eventually when I had a
psilocybin experience I found out what
the meaning of God yeah yeah I was shown
what religion is supposed to give you
yeah just a genuine mystical experience
yes in a connection with the divine and
ever since that trip you know I have
moments of despair and doubt you know
but by and large I faith that spirit is
guiding my life and the world at large
mm-hmm what does the connection with the
divine feel like for you mmm sense of
deep peace mm-hmm and as I mentioned
earlier about one of my insights from
mushrooms a sense that fundamentally
everything will be okay interesting how
does one balance the piece of everything
gonna be okay with this what we just
were talking about what there's a need
for philosophers and ethicists to be
paired together with these exponential
technology builders you know there's
like kind of like a you gotta have a
little like fire under your ass to like
do that yeah yeah yeah because if you're
just like I am at a sea if I'm at peace
let me just go off in a mountain and how
does how does that work how about that's
a great question I don't know if I could
speak to it in words but I do I do have
this impulse to make the world a better
place and fight for justice and love
well at the same time cultivating that
sense of peace that I know is it at root
what we are it take us take us to a
basic decision like you can either
choose to do something related to your
hustle to bring change to the world for
the five-hour chunk of time or you can
choose to like go take a hike by the
ocean you know these are hard decision
there's a very hard I wish I can give
you a simple prescriptive yeah
intuitions been guiding me in that
regard figuring out what the next step
is when is it time to act when is it
time to retreat mm-hmm yeah that's
that's been cultivated that intuitions
been cultivated over the years and where
do you feel intuition just like my belly
button
belly bag right underneath yeah and I
start with that and I how does it feel
about the filter it through how does
that feel
the intuition yeah yeah well depending
on what the decision is or what the
question is
sometimes intuition could be a sharp
constriction telling me don't do this
other times it can be yes go forward
okay and that's a very morally key for
great yes that exactly thank you for it
interesting and then where does so where
does that travel through your Google
we're saying it's going through
somewhere sure yeah it's I definitely
filter it through logic who reason and
reasoning yes and if those things align
okay that's my North Star okay yeah no
interesting yes and then when there's a
non-aligned disconnect yeah then I need
to take more time take your time yes
and then this is kind of like how you
can take your life on this where you
feel really connected with spirit
guiding you but at the same time you're
still making these decisions with the
combined sense of intuition plus
reasoning to decide and you can be
patient when you need right that's a
really important one it would be patient
mm-hmm
yeah patience is in short supply
nowadays gotta go go go go I want
enlightenment in a five-minute video if
you guys aren't in line by this video
the said guru says is so well that we
spend like 12 years learning a language
but we want enlightenment in five
minutes
well it kind of puts in a perspective
like yeah chill out and invest the time
into working and evolving your
consciousness over time yeah at the
deepest level there was no rush you know
Jeff Brown says the soul doesn't know a
thing about deadlines yeah yeah oh yeah
you know interesting at the same time
though it's like within the Northstar
there's some sort of like I do have some
sort of goals that I want to bring to
the world during this North Star journey
so technically I don't want to maybe I
want to get one of the goals done by the
time I'm 30 and remember a time I'm 60
and stuff like that yeah yeah I think
it's important and the example you bring
up is to really connect with that
intuition instead of the conditioning
that tells you I need to have X before
I'm 30 any to have Y yes so and then
what about your we talked about this a
little bit on the journey with
omniscience so that's a bit about your
first like so I have an experience and
tapping into that what and what does
that um nisshin's you said it feels like
peace that like all is in the direction
that it's going it's like along the DAO
this path the way it's happening yes
well I can't feel like peace I can't
feel like these yeah sometimes the
journey is not so classified yeah sorry
but so what was it takes a lot of work
yeah yes
so you're just looking for more a little
bit more about omniscience but we kind
of touched on that and then you
mentioned this a little bit earlier but
a lot of the indigenous wisdoms are
pointing towards our disconnection from
nature being the reason why we have so
many of the blood lensses and how that
you said that for like that first
principle that we could do to be a
butterfly and civilization is by tuning
more deeply in word and also by tuning
more deeply with nature letting that
tune us like a fork yeah let's let's do
the relationship with trauma and this
holistic mental healing mhm
sure yes yeah well regarding holistic
mental healing trauma is one piece okay
a very important piece I would say are
we all born with some sort of either
like ancestral trauma I would say so
okay or we get some trauma within the
first like a couple months or years of
being child or then within our teenage
years
there's always it's an I mean it's
impossible for the one guy who goes
through life without accumulating trauma
I would call [ __ ] but I mean Stan
Grof says you know the birth is a trauma
interesting yeah and and a bliss at the
same time so trauma and ecstasy mm-hmm
you just like god you're just it's just
wrong yeah well I guess it can be both
I'm thinking in terms of just the the
construed being safe in the womb and
then this constriction and birth and to
using a otic native environment rules
which there's a baby that's like an very
traumatic whoa experience and Stan Grof
has written a lot about this people when
they have holotropic breathwork sessions
they can oftentimes access these
memories from birth and the pain and
suffering that they felt
from birth oh my goodness yeah just from
leaving the container of the womb into
the chaos yeah like people can go back
and like remember that and he says you
know a lot of people have issues with
like constriction they process that
trauma in the holotropic state and
issues resolved hmm it's incredible okay
so yeah so tell teaches about these
processing trauma techniques yeah and
these are that's only one part of the
whole the sickness of correct yeah
well there's a lot of different ways to
heal trauma one of the most important
pieces is to feel safe to find a safe
container to where you can process
trauma a lot of times you'll have to
have someone supporting you or guiding
you it's very difficult to fully process
your trauma without having a
short-circuit because you just can't do
it on your own mm-hm
so with you know psychedelic therapy
MDMA is really useful here because it
gives you that sense of safety you know
deactivates the amygdala responsible for
your fear response and heightened set to
in prefrontal cortex so that combined
with psychotherapy the safe container
and the guide and support you all very
conducive to healing trauma mm-hmm
reconnecting with your body is very
important when you're traumatized you
dissociate from your body the body is a
dangerous place
mmm right so any modality somatic
practice that helps you body yoga breath
work different forms of exercise massage
okay so could for those that may not
have like access to a psychedelic
psychotherapy yeah it's something like
like what Ori does with holding space is
that we find like maybe a friend or a
relative or something like Papa does
that work for trying on trauma
integration yeah I mean I'm still
learning a lot about it but my sense is
that sometimes if your support system
isn't wise knowledgeable enough the
trauma they can reach Rama ties you if
it comes up and it's not processed
properly you can read traumatize you so
it's important that whoever is there to
support you that's what they're doing
yes okay so if we have like an
experienced healer that we're sitting
down with then someone that can also
help us realize that we ourselves are
the ones that heal ourselves not like a
pair of Google sure yeah but right so
the basically the better the person that
we sit down with the more we could even
potentially get away with not needing it
like a psychedelic psychotherapy or
stuff like that some person some people
it's like hell yeah let's do that for
other people it's like what else is
there that I can try as well and so it's
cool to see the different potential
paths that one could do for this I think
it depends too on the severity of the
trauma hmm it's a very severe trauma
it's best to get some like proper
support mm-hmm
but there's many traumas where you can
just chip away gradually on your own
through those modalities that I
mentioned to me yeah there's a really
like really simple ones like ones fear
of like swimming
you know just like can you look at a
swing just look at this yeah can you
look at it you know and you like start
like titrating yourself you like put a
finger in the exactly that drop yeah
yeah voluntary exposure to it what you
fear yeah yeah that's it yeah that's it
and manageable doses in a manageable
titrated voluntary exposure good tve
voluntary exposure that's great that's
actually I would say a really big
principle of it okay all right so then
what are the other aspects of holistic
mental thank you right yes yeah so I
would say diet is a big one ooh you know
very fundamental things proper hydration
sleeping but but diet specifically a lot
of diet is very muddy waters to dive
into you know everyone's biology is
different so it's it's really about
exploring and experimenting with what
works for you some people can have
gluten some people can't you know so
getting that in check is important it's
kind of like feeling really tapping
deeply into how you feel after you put
stuff in your body intuitive eating
intuitive eating this yeah big practice
and like Hara Hachi boo like eat until
you're like 80% fuller so mmm don't over
eat like a main principle right yeah
intermittent fasting intermittent
fasting is a massive one pretty useful
don't just be like constantly eating
things all day long but like mm-hmm just
have a meal at noon and a meal at 6:00
or whatever and then just wait until the
next day
mm-hmm like and again some people can't
do
their metabolism interests one love for
it okay so really how does that even
that principle of intermittent fasting
is could only be good for like eighty
percent of people or anything right it
just depends yeah so yeah and then
hydration you said yeah afford I saw
mm-hmm so the water is also one of those
things where it's like certain people
are like two cups a day others are eight
cups a day mm-hmm maybe I'm like running
a [ __ ] load and the heat and so I need
more water typing mm-hmm
again Taylor specifically yeah for you
yeah depends on your exercise and
everything else intuitive drinking
intuitive drinking I like that yeah and
then also you know relationships is a
big one having nourishing fulfilling
relationships finding work that you find
nourishing fulfilling the environment is
a big one that people often leave out
you know the spaces that are around you
and more broadly society at large you
know I think we have this spike in
depression and anxiety and mental health
issues it's not because we're all
genetically predisposed to it right
there is something happening in the
broader environment that is contributing
to this epidemic that we seeing it's why
we in many ways why we left downtown San
Francisco and yeah it was just not as
conducive to spiritual growth mm-hmm and
mental health yeah you know there's
pretty classic analogy about the bad or
good Apple and a bad barrel you know
yeah you can't be a tuning fork in the
matrix for so long to be able to go and
and grow the strength of the tuning fork
by letting nature to new better exactly
and it support you and into the
direction of that you want to go in I
mean if you're constantly using your
energy to fight and swim upstream yeah
you'll get burnt down exhausted you need
an environment that supports your
highest potential highest calling
what percentage of us that's
massive an environment that helps you
get to your north start and what
percentage would you allocate
hypothetically of
metropolis living to depression and
anxiety yeah just gonna throw out a
number yeah I'll try afterward - I'm
gonna say 80 No
80 80 tonight I don't know I I think
there's some oh my god
maybe you're right when this is over
I'll probably or maybe my new baby right
yeah it might be that high yeah well I
just think the the the lifestyle of city
life is so fragmented and it's so
difficult to find nourishing community
yes and space and time and your nature
yeah everything is hustle hustle bustle
you know so it's it's challenging in
urban environments yeah damn yeah I like
how just straight up your with that yeah
yeah I mean you listed also like you
know diet like food as another one of
these that could be a massive
contributor as well when we're eating
fake foods we're much more likely to
experience mental health issues yeah
then we're your body my connection yeah
absolutely so there's like there's gonna
be a lot of variables to crunch but the
urban concrete jungles that we live in
in the way that then how that further
structures of the way that we have
community and these healthy
relationships and all these like
variables that we're talking about yeah
versus actually putting your hands in
the soil growing food all this type of
stuff exactly mm-hmm but what do you do
for healthy relationships like let's
talk family
let's talk intimate partners let's talk
friends yeah what do you how do you do
that for yourself and how do you
recommend others to assure sure so
that's shifted a lot
over the years but again I think one big
answer is dealing with your trauma with
regards to family I had a lot of
resentment towards my father and many
other members of my family and it wasn't
until I was able to process that fully
and grieve in come to terms with that
that I was able to reenter relationships
with them that were much healthier and
same goes for friendships how do you get
your family to grieve with you yeah hard
to crack family is you know Ram Dass as
I quote if you think you're enlightened
spending a week with your family yeah I
mean family is the hardest one I think
you definitely need space and time away
from them
oh yes sir there was a great comic it
was the the the monks having their last
tests at the monastery and it was like
now for your last test you must go and
sit with the family over Thanksgiving
and then the monks just sitting there at
the dinner table trying to like be
meditative well there's chaos I think
across the veil yeah it's a very
humbling experience yes
and then like Buddha yeah okay okay one
week with the fam yeah go do that Yeah
right okay so how did you get to the
grieving with the fam how'd you open
them up like that
well processing my own drama with a
therapist but then having done that I
was much more capable of bringing up
issues between us in a very
compassionate and calm
Manor yeah I wasn't projecting I wasn't
blaming or you know demonizing them for
what they did I was okay at that point
I've processed the trauma in the
grieving and so that invites them to be
more open and vulnerable instead of up
being on the defense ooh I love that so
so approaching our families in a more in
a way after we've our selves have looked
at ourselves in the mirror and worked on
our own honest true trauma that we need
to integrate ourselves and then we kind
of approach them with a more
compassionate angle not in a not in a
way where we're trying to project some
things sort of change they need to do
but just to ask a question and to be
kind and gentle and loving that's been
totally working for me as well and I
know many others so that's that's great
to hear
yeah what about um intimate
relationships and friends so yeah I mean
similar principle there was definitely
certain experiences related to friends
that were traumatizing in the past and
for a long time
that blocked me off from cultivating
deep new friendships same goes for
intimate relationships see if you don't
heal a broken heart you don't have the
capacity to enter a new romantic
relationship so short answer again
process your trauma yeah how would you
heal a broken heart after a yeah it
seems like the one of the important
things that I've learned is just to do
as amicable of a job as possible in
relationships that that split up whether
it be you know intimate or even like you
know business really
not just be as loving and amicable as
possible who are they about to
experience easier said than done
sometimes you know it's like I said if
you have harboring resentment it's much
harder to be loving right but if you've
if you've processed your trauma you
you're much more likely to be at peace
and you can always more amicably mm-hmm
and then where does also on the holistic
mental healing where does the but where
does where do other basic things like
sleep or exercise
what are those kick in and how do you
how do you handle those how do you
recommend understand all those sure well
again I'd be intuitive sleeping just the
few that I'm gonna have an intuitive
protocol yeah for me it's different you
know I exercise two or three days a week
depending on what injuries I have it
shifts so I like running a lot I play
soccer but it's definitely incredibly
grounding I mean if I go two weeks
without exercise I can sense mmm myself
with brain fog and being Moody and it's
not good so yeah I think again they
tailored and specific to individual
needs and capacities mm-hmm you know and
I'm a sleeping side as well
mm-hmm I got a nice mattress yeah that's
a big key mm-hmm yeah yeah there's a
good book I haven't read it yet but I
listened to the podcast Matthew Walker
yeah why we solutely he's on fire we
love him yeah he's great and that really
blew my mind about how important sleep
is those yeah very crucial fundamentals
it's like mix it makes a ton of sense
it's like oh yeah I've lived 26 years
and like what I learned today I have to
integrate with the 26 years of memories
like that's why we sleep yes defragment
today yeah kind of like makes a lot of
sense yeah I mean you go insane if you
don't sleep yeah for long
yep so far yeah there's also like tons
of simulations that we run about during
sleep so like were constantly running
simulations injuries dreams yeah never
heard it I'm simulating tonight I'm
simulating yeah enjoy your simulations
yes yeah right on the way to bed how do
you ever listen dreamed oh yeah yeah
lucid dreams amazing you know I've done
it a few times yeah I don't know how I
did it but I wish I could figure yeah
there's like massive T's such an easy
one it's just like looking at your hand
I was just gonna say the easy one is
just to do things like think about
yourself in control before you go to bed
mmm like also don't think about negative
[ __ ] like think about positive things
and try and like manifest your destiny
into the world as you're like going to
bed like be thinking about how you're
building and like what you're working on
and stuff or like if you really want to
go and like like going like planet hop
like to different star systems or like
whatever you want to do just like really
just you want to go is like in the
bottom of the Mariana Trench whatever
you wanna do but then light up hopping
right it sort of hopping like you're
going to bed while you're thinking about
that and being in control and then the
higher propensity for that also curse
but then right yeah there's a lot of
yeah that's it that's that's a big one
no other other core areas for holistic
words lately mm-hmm I think we touched
on the big ones you know I think I
mentioned connection to nature
yeah but that comes with healing trauma
I think yeah that's a big one and then
what about our own journey like we were
talking about this a little bit before
the show started but like these first
couple principles like the first
principle you're born it's like remember
we all come from sore
the second principle is what is your
purpose why'd you come here what is your
North Star and how can you most
effectively endeavor towards that yeah
do you how do you feel about those two
hours like first principles in this
notion of North Star yeah yeah well I
really resonate with the North Star
notion and as well as coming from
sources were born although I don't
remember what happened before
but in terms of finding your North Star
if that's you notice what you're excited
about what makes you come alive you can
pursue that what do you spend a lot of
time researching listening to and being
interested in yeah and there's also the
notion of a key guy have you heard of
this a key key guy it's a Japanese
principle a key guy yeah okay so it's
four concentric circles okay and in the
middle is a key guide that's true that's
North Star okay so it's what you're good
at what the world needs what you can get
paid for yeah and I'm forgetting the
fourth one
yeah what you're passionate about yeah
those are yeah those are awesome yeah in
the north side right in the center of
those yeah they're over laughing they're
overlapping yeah there's an eccentric
service or their Co centric meaning
completely embedded within each other no
no those over lo overlapping over Yoko
yeah so that's how I approach the North
Star yeah that's good
and also there's got to be like a little
bit of vigilance with like this notion
of like what are what are you like
enjoying doing because we can like catch
ourselves being subscribed to certain
maybe media sources or certain
activities that we think bring us
enjoyment and but are really actually
extremely detrimental to our psyche you
know it's all that cetera so it's like
yeah yeah deprogramming yourself
deconditioning it's important yeah yeah
there's this idea of like false
resonance right
uh-huh so you might think you're
resonating with something but you're
really just it's a wound attachment wall
you know bird hard Gunther yeah had I'm
gonna show twice you did we love him
okay
yeah yeah he does a great article on
false resonance yep you guys should
check out yeah yeah yeah it was me go do
it a third time going down to SoCal
that's mom so they already in touch with
him that's a good point should do
how about a spiritual bypass mm-hmm what
is that how do we avoid it that kind of
has a little bit of like that false
resonance yeah exactly
yeah totally yeah so the notion of
spiritual bypassing is using spiritual
ideas or practices to prematurely
transcend the more difficult messy human
side of life so difficult emotions
difficult issues obligations in your
life an example being you are neglecting
your daughter and you justify it by
saying I mean this is a pretty extreme
example I don't think this is actually
the case but you just felt by saying
it's okay everything will be okay
remember I was saying like fundamentally
everything you use these absolute
spiritual principles to bypass the more
relative truths mm-hmm about the nature
of our lives in the world yes yeah so
it's often the case when it comes to
grieving if you let's say lose a loved
one I mean this was the case in my life
when I lost my best friend in high
school
spirituality was a crutch that I used
and I'll be at a necessary crutch for a
long time but eventually it sabotage my
growth and but what I really needed was
to process my emotions and they can
grieve yeah instead of attaching the
spiritual ideas
this this one's a nuts because it makes
me really reflect more deeply on my own
life trajectory and my own instances of
have I really been authentically working
on myself and not just by passing
thoughts like that and then also just
like on a on a level of everyone's you
know spiritual journey it's you know how
well are we facing these relative truths
versus just trying to bypass them mm-hmm
this also reminds me of what you're
teaching about with you called it the
spoonfuls of cosmic juice it's so funny
it's like yeah people are kind of like
not taking their time to integrate a
mystical spiritually developing
experience and instead they're just
diving right back in right back in yeah
I mean it's it's it makes sense why
because when you have any a mystical
experience or a peak psychedelic
experience you might enter a very
blissful state you might feel totally
connected to yourself and others in
nature and you think ah okay this is
where I want to be but then it wears off
and you think how can I get back there
so you constantly go back for that
spoonful of cosmic juice and eventually
it becomes poison yeah yeah relying on
something exhaustion ously to get you to
interconnected with source mm-hmm is a
recipe for disaster well well not even
exhaustion you can do a floatation tank
you could do you could be addicted to
breath work you can do all sorts of
practices mm-hmm that enable you to
bypass integration into really work so
you're constantly getting that hit of
bliss from whatever practice methodology
maybe instead of doing the hard work of
integration applying what you've learned
from the experience embodying that
deeply yeah before moving on to have
another peak experience or new you know
whatever so that's such a massive
principle that's another
when the flag mmm really do the
integration
focus on that yeah something I need to
get much much better at - yeah I'm
spending a lot of time on having
different conscious evolutions and then
I just need to have more time on just
really reflecting and integrating that's
such a key it's well right now I'm doing
a lot of writing on it or maybe
recording a video on the subject that
kind of stuff in here which are all in
journal ssing that way it's very useful
yeah yeah that one's really useful you
familiar with the right-hand path first
left-hand path and kind of like uni we
fall from grace from source and then the
idea is that okay like we got to
reconnect to source right we've been
mentioning that mm-hm
and so then one idea is this like right
hand path which is this like pure path
of like meditation and since yourself
work and Yatta Yatta left-hand path it's
like I'm gonna do drugs and I'm going to
do
BDSM I'm a sex drugs rock girl yeah
we're your thoughts on that
mm yeah I think it comes down to
intention and
awareness you could have you know you
could be participating in a ready to hem
path in a very unhealthy way just
because you might be meditating and
using these pure methods let's say to
reach enlightenment doesn't mean it
can't be toxic
you could spiritually bypass by just
meditating every day instead of dealing
with things you know you should be
dealing with and same goes for the left
for more obvious reasons yes I think it
comes down to ya attention and how
you're utilizing practices from both
sides okay I mean sex is Tantra you can
use Tantra in a very healthy way to to
spiritually grow music you know doesn't
have to be all toxic yeah and then how
about this conversation that we had at
that conscious hacking event this notion
that is it possible that more people
will heal mentally and holistically
faster and more effectively around our
world can we increase the level of
consciousness around our world and then
faster and more effectively by helping
people meet their basic needs and we see
it being proposed in a multitude of ways
one of the ways is this basic income
that is being proposed to run little
trials of around the planet and then
people are countering that and saying
what about universal basic assets about
a basic asset ownership mm-hmm what
about the North Star thing giving people
money or assets is cool but like what
about North Stars like so like the stuff
to have something to wake up to and be
passionate about every day but it's that
easier to find if they have that little
bit of like safety so they don't have to
worry about food and shelter yeah walk
us Tom your thought
or sure exactly what you were saying it
facilitates the process of finding your
Northstar because your attention isn't
scattered trying to meet your basic
needs and also having the psychological
security of knowing if I choose a
different path in life than the one I'm
currently on I will be okay to a certain
degree and that gives you space and time
to really dig into your own curiosities
and passions that you might otherwise
neglected because of you know 95
dead-end job but or yeah and then what
about like unlike a simulated level like
what happens with this redistribution of
assets or of wealth like honor just the
simulated level like run the simulation
out a couple of years does it seem like
that there's still a good way to
incentivize people to want to achieve
their dreams and earn a financial
success but not feel like there's some
sort of like a cap or a heavy tax on
them but that there we are still really
taking care of the community our
neighbors our most vulnerable people in
abling those North Star journeys to be
more effective
can we really balance those out well
mm-hmm
with the basic assets you mean yeah with
like a balance between people still
feeling like the economic redistribution
of wealth and assets is simultaneously
yes helping those most vulnerable that
need those those North Star journeys
more effectively but also doesn't put
some sort of like a an inhibition on
people to achieve
right so Yanis varoufakis he talks about
this a lot he's a Greek finance minister
but he talks about you bi is much more
much better at liberating people because
it provides a foundation whereas most
welfare provides safety nets and that's
are very easy to get caught in mmm right
there's a lot of perverse incentives
that comes with a lot of the basic
assets in terms of when you reach a
certain financial bracket when you lose
it and you lose your benefits right so
it disincentivizes people from working
and pursuing different things in life
bill with the ubi you get it regardless
and you can apply it whatever way you
want it gives you more freedom
damn it see me crazy to see what the
United States China and these other
economic powerhouses around the world
decide to do with the automation age and
wealth inequality and yeah it's just
gonna be really interesting to see what
happens yeah the facilitation of the
North Star journeys is critical bringing
people most meaning meeting their basic
needs because that those creative fruits
get to be expressed to all of us and
shared by all of us right to questions
that we ask our guests on the way out of
the show's first is are we in a
simulation I don't know
I think that's very similar to is there
a God question mm-hmm okay why why do
you say that because if we are then who
is the simulator who was who created
simulation must be some kind of God
figure it just yeah I don't know it's it
to me it's it's not as relevant to my
own my own life whether no simulation
but it may soon become more relevant to
all of our lives once we have the power
to run our own this is true yeah yeah
it's gonna be become way more relevant
with computational capacity and
immersive experiences and realities all
that kind of so it's just gonna be crazy
yeah we're already running our own
little simulated experiments of all of
all different sorts but when you can do
it on like a planetary level and mm-hmm
how did they discover language how did
they discover the Internet you know like
and just be able to watch how people
engaged on those what is the most
beautiful thing in the world that's a
good one yeah man I want to say music I
like what Jordan Peterson says about
music he talks about all these different
layers coming together in the lining
mm-hmm there's something deeply resonant
about that for me yeah it reminds me of
divinity yeah everything coming together
yeah and like the symphony that is
civilization and all of us as our notes
the symphony of life yes yeah of life
yeah we want to play or Institute our
instrument and play music together yes
yes to in the instrument and play the
note play the music all together yes
that actually brings us to the gem thing
- it's like tuning it is kind of like
getting the dust and stuff off and then
playing it is bringing it up having the
light shine through it so it's been such
a fun episode yeah yeah it's great yeah
super fun thanks for coming on really
appreciate it thank you yeah thanks for
all the great work we is such an
important topic who is still mental
healing and all the components that you
broke it down into thanks for doing that
and doing the work and hopefully it
resonated with other people that have
been tuning in thank you everyone for
watching we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear our thoughts in the
comments below on the episode and topics
that we talked about less than what
you're thinking have more conversation
through your friends family co-workers
people online on social media about
holistic mental healing all these little
sub components we talked about have more
conversations about go and take control
of those aspects of your life more
vigorously and bring them to fruition
and check out the links on the bio below
to tony's profiles check them out up
support him support us support
simulation our links are below support
the artists entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders educators that you believe in
support them you find our Pay Pal
patreon cryptocurrency links below also
shout out to Horry Shapira for producing
thank you very much Laurie
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thanks for tuning in
and we'll see you soon